ciao a tutti donald trump a è il nuovo
presidente americano io già
l'irrefrenabile voglia di bruciare il
mio passaporto senza contare che anche
se non lo potete vedere questa mattina
mi sono svegliato e solo mia faccia e
comparso un brufolo grande quanto un
picasso di piccola taglia le curve il
make up consigliera non lo so tipo un
correttore sui toni del verde per
coprirlo io invece usato maixner a
parlare male di trump a porta sfiga ecco
perché ho deciso di cambiare
atteggiamento io amo trump loving fra
weekend ronde chiaro trump io amo trump
di trump amo il messaggio che porta con
sé i soldi e piva risorse già i soldi se
non merda sordi nel senso di soldi
naturalmente non di sordi che non
sentono perché noi ci fanno schifo
portatori di handicap
chi ha detto che i soldi non fanno la
felicità era chiaramente povero i poveri
sono i nostri lettori migliori perché
solo zero assoluto
mettili uno dietro l'altro e cipe
miliardi trumps visto lungo vogliamo
parlare delle donne basta fi carucci con
le rose con vostra madre con la vostra
ragazza e cobas tra figlia le donne sono
tutti oggetti sessuali sono tipo delle
bambole gonfiabili solo che parlano un
sacco specialmente quando sono già
essere l'unico motivo per cui le
femministe hanno bruciato i reggiseni e
perché non erano di victoria's secret
altrimenti col cavolo che ti bruciavano
80 euro di push up una donna con un
opinione è come un forno con le ascelle
inutile spero che grazie a tre poi venga
loro tolto il diritto di voto tranello e
quelle che sostengono tram plan le donne
che odiano se stesse sono le uniche che
vogliamo su questo pianeta di misogini
anzi quello dico che è caduta al dolore
io mi vergogno di avere
impersonato in passato perché un vero
uomo non si mette le parrucche un vero
uomo si mette il parrucchino
gli immigrati sono anche peggio sono più
sporchi salute che r
se fanno esplodere ma che è campo minato
ma lasciamo stare che senza contare i
nativi l'intera popolazione americana è
immigrata non ci porta perchè lo sanno
pure i bambini che tutti gli immigrati
fanno le sparatorie spaccia non lo so
perché chi mi fa sull eroina e cuba sono
nove perché l'olio diritti piace così
tanto perché cinesi ci metto la cocaina
dentro il sushi o ma poi gli immigrati
ruba nei nostri posti di lavoro ma voi
sapete quanti fra dovrebbero fare il
lavapiatti l'avete gli stoppa cessi
tutti i puri laureati immigrati superano
le nostre donne ecco perché tuo figlio
emulato e che i solari cai che i suoi
peggio quelle che si professano cai ma
stanno sempre a piangere ha detto potete
radio maria che chiesto il motivo dei
terremoti della tromba d'aria accesa i
gay grazie grinder stanno attirando su
di noi un cataclisma naturale dopo
l'altro prima o poi si abbatterà su di
me quel gran [ __ ] di godzilla ma
pensiamo ai nostri figli soprattutto ma
che cosa penseranno i bambini quando
vedranno queste omosessuali fari
coreografie dei musical per strada non
facciamo gli stessi errori che abbiamo
fatto in passato vi prego vogliamo far
parlare statistiche quanti bambini sono
diventati neri dopo aver visto magrebini
vendere tappeti per strada immaginatevi
cosa accadrà un domani vi dico solo tre
parole donna immigrante lesbica il male
un horror peggio di the ring sette
giorni signora la stessa parte grazie ad
un'altra me che ho fatto una grandissima
scoperta che l'anello di congiunzione
fra l'uomo e la scimmia è fra noi e ha
il diritto di voto io non voglio neanche
immaginare che cosa penserà obama che
per otto anni si è fatto un culo così
per cercare di migliorare l'america anni
passati a costruire questo castello di
carta arriva il primo genio che lo butta
gioco una scoreggia trump vuole alzare
un muro per non far entrare i messicani
negli stati uniti ma secondo me dopo la
sua lezione col cazzo che avessi che
ricevo
negli stati uniti quindi il muro non c'è
bisogno di alzarlo so anche che tra le
persone che guardano questo video ci
sarà qualcuno che penserà che le
elezioni americani non dovrebbero
interessarci perché ci abita militare
ragazze leader colosseo in tal caso o
benvenuto sul mio canale emerito cretini
lascio qua sotto anni e password bannati
da solo basta definirci uomini e donne
italiani o stranieri è etero gay siamo
esseri umani siamo cittadini del mondo
america una forza mondiale la
californication e una realtà per
comparare tutti gli accordi che abbiamo
firmato negli stati uniti e che vuol
dire che quel centreranno il nazista
prima o poi finirà anche nelle vostre
case che non ci potrete fare lo tzatziki
a chi segue questo canale invece la
prima di questo video chiedo scusa odio
fare satira politica specialmente fatto
in maniera approssimativa ma dal momento
che non e merito incapace e stato eletto
presidente degli stati uniti che sono
detto ma perché non sono anche tu ma ciò
che mi sconvolge di più in assoluto
sono tutti quegli italiani che su
internet sostengono trama poi però mi
ricordo che esistono italiani che votano
salvini e tutto ha un senso
peccato che sia contro marcia nella
tangenziale a 200 all'ora
voglio chiudere infine questo video con
un messaggio positivo perché credo che
la speranza debba essere l'ultima a
morire
scappate su marte finché cesa opposti
[Musica]